celebrations in the capital khartoum as
a political standoff de-escalates
in a gesture of peace Sudan's ruling
military freed more than 200 rebel
fighters who are part of the country's
opposition a step towards reconciliation
one rebel leader praised their release
it shows clearly that the Army and the
Armed Forces are our partners and not
our enemy with cooperation and
understanding we will meet the demands
of the Sudanese people those demands are
for civilian rule it's been the heart of
the conflict which began after the
military ousted longtime leader Omar
al-bashir activists called for a
transition to a civilian government an
impasse ensued and then bloodshed in
June security forces opened fire on a
protest camp in the capital leaving more
than 100 dead but after a month the
warring sides were at the table again in
power sharing talks mediated by the
African Union and Ethiopia after two
days a breakthrough was announced the
two parties have agreed to share the
sovereign council equally between the
military and civilian for the period of
at least three years also agreed on an
independent civilian government under
the leadership of a prime minister in a
further sign of healing they also agreed
to launch a national independent
investigation into the deaths of the
Sudanese who were killed in the fight
for democracy in DWI Ibrahim joins me in
the studio now for some analysis ayah
you have reported extensively from Sudan
for us tell us about the significance of
this deal it's a significant deal in
that it is actually it is the
culmination of about two and a half
months of this uncertainty between the
protesters in the military
and negotiations that have been going on
on and off since the removal of amber
and Bashir on April 11th the but this is
by no means the first time that it looks
like the military council and the
protester leaders have reached a deal
there were many ups and downs in in this
almost three month period with the
military sometimes backing away from
quite big concessions at the very last
minute so it remains to be seen if the
deal will actually hold however this is
the first time that we have a deal that
as a result of a mediation before that
it was the military council and the
protest leaders negotiating directly
with each other but this is the first
fruit of the African Union and the
Ethiopian mediators and the most
important thing to remember the most
significant thing about these years that
this is not this is by no stretch of the
imagination a civilian civilian rule
because there might be a confusion
people went out demanding civilian rule
what people are telling me is that
that's still what they want this is a
power-sharing agreement that may or may
not lead to civilian rule in a couple of
years following the culmination of the
transitional period but that remains to
be seen okay so potentially a good first
step as you say you're in touch with
people in Sudan what are they saying do
they have confidence that this is going
in the right direction so before we get
into what people are saying it's
important to remember that all of this
entire negotiation is happening with a
near internet blackout that affects most
of the people in Sudan and the internet
was cut off by the state and so and the
state obviously has command of the of
them of the official channels of
communications so state media with that
being said we were able to reach some
people on the ground and the reactions
have been mixed there's a general
feeling that it's a compromise but there
were no other options that the the
forces of freedom and change had to
realize that any kind of agreement would
have to involve the military and that
some compromise needed to need it to be
reached and that the TMC had to be
included which which which was not
always the the aspiration of the
of the protest movement but there are
people that are disappointed and you
know they are disappointed to still see
to still see the faces that have that
were prominent in the Beshear era
whether it's committee the RSF commander
or berhan who was the head of the
transitional merit or military council
there's also an important clause in this
agreement that vows to investigate the
atrocities on the streets but then there
are big question marks about whether the
people that are allegedly complicit in
these atrocities can investigate
themselves how fair would that be and as
as we've been saying it remained it
really remains to be seen if this
agreement will hold because at any time
the military still commends the power to
basically call it off and take power
completely alright DW is ayah ibrahim
thanks so much